by Neil Irwin who covers economics
issues for the Washington Post and you
must have been fairly busy yesterday
you've got to feature articles in the
business section this morning just for
sort of setting the ground rules here in
terms of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac for
our viewers what are these two
institutions what do they do well
they're kind of unusual hybrid
institutions they are private companies
they're owned by shareholders you can
buy or sell their stock on the New York
Stock Exchange however they were created
by the government to further the goal of
stabilizing the home mortgage market try
and make it easy for people to get a
home loan and buy a house and this has
created some unusual conflict they are
in many ways a kind of duck billed
platypus of the corporate world they are
kind of government kind of kind of
private and that's created some problems
recently because people who buy their
debt people who lend them money assume
that if worse comes to worse the federal
government will will back it and even
though both the companies themselves in
the government for many years have said
that's not the case there is no federal
guarantee people assume there is and so
that's create a difficult situation as
they've run into problems the last few
months and and last thing last week
things started to shake up with both of
those institutions with their stock
price what happened and then what
happened over the weekend how did
government officials react that's right
over the last couple of weeks there's
been kind of a loss of faith in the
company's people on Wall Street and
world markets have been not so sure that
they have enough capital they have
enough money to make it through the the
kind of losses they'll be encountering
in the in the months and years ahead as
as this housing problem continues to get
worse so people lost some of that faith
and and their stock as you say well
quite dramatically as at one point
Freddie Mac shares traded for three
dollars and eighty-nine cents on Friday
morning which is a kind of remarkable
for a big established company so what
happened over the weekend the the
government is trying to avoid a
situation where it has to back all these
debts and so what secretary of the
Treasury henry paulson and the Federal
Reserve did was come up with an
agreement that Congress expects to pass
the next week or two to give the
Treasury the authority to lend money to
Freddie and Fannie and the authority if
they must to buy stock in the company's
but not the obligation to do so so the
idea is to calm the markets by saying
there is the federal government here if
it's needed but not to actually inject
government money just yet about what
what percentage of mortgage is in the US
are held by Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac of
total outstanding mortgages about half
but what's remarkable is in the last
several months as as you well know the
private mortgage markets have dried up
nobody you know banks or having problems
and nobody wants to lend money so in the
first quarter this year Fannie and
Freddie were responsible for about
seventy percent of mortgages about 68 of
leaf which is uh that's a lot so their
accounting for a vast amount of the
lending that's occurring right now we're
going up onto our phone lines for your
questions from neil irwin of the
washington post about Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac and the government's
reaction 20 27 37 triple zero to four
Democrats 20 27 37 triple zero one for
Republicans independents and all others
20 26 28 0205 in the business section
the Washington Post you penned two
articles one we talked about a little
bit about how how the Treasury has
reacted and the Fed also acted yesterday
to make some new rules about about
so-called shady lending practices what
have they said well these are these are
more forward-looking these rules that
the Federal Reserve agreed to yesterday
or not nothing that's going to help the
immediate crisis nothing that's going to
help people who made a you know took out
a loan they can't really afford in 2005
or 2006 what these are is our rules to
try and prevent lenders from from
engaging practices that in retrospect
look quite unwise and have heard a lot
of people starting in october two
thousand nine for example if you're
making loans that are above basically
you you you have to verify the income
and assets of the people you're making
loan to now that might sound like an
obvious thing a banker would want to do
but but a lot of people we're not doing
that a lot of lenders we're not doing
that in 2005-2006 that will change in
2009 let's go to our first call newberry
south carolina republican caller good
morning your first up good morning I'd
like to ask you just a question isn't it
true that when somebody goes under on
that is that the government or the
fattiness Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac each
the difference or absorbs the loss and
when the government bailed Fannie Mae or
Freddie Mac out it's in it really
indirectly they're bailing out the
homeowner who originally lost and alone
so I guess what I'm trying to say is
everybody is mad at the government for
bailing out big business but really
what's causing indirectly them to have
have to be bailed out if there is no
default by the homeowner who lost the
money and it's just a progression as
somebody's going to get bailed out and
in essence that's what bothers news your
people talk about business being bailed
out no and the individual isn't bailed
out but in a way that's what's happening
the individuals bailed out through that
mechanism albeit going through fannie
mae and freddie mac which your guests
agree with that that's about right a
little more complicated than that but
but you have the right idea what happens
is when Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac they
buy a mortgage from the bank or other
lender and they package those mortgages
into into securities and they what they
do is they guarantee that that there
will not be losses on those securities
so they are in effect backing the loans
that you ultimately took out even though
you might never know that fannie or
freddie was involved you don't have any
interaction with them they are providing
back into that loan what people mean
when they when they say that they're
bailing out homeowners if you fall
behind on your mortgage it's not that
they are going to make you whole they
make the guy who lent you the money the
investor hole however in the long run
what what these companies are trying to
do is make more capital available make
more funding available for for
homeowners and so in that sense they are
they are indeed helping helping people
we're ordinary Americans trying to buy a
house Clinton Pennsylvania next up
Democratic caller good morning
Pennsylvania you're gonna have to turn
down your television or radio your
feedback on its go ahead make sure you
mute your television of radio Clinton PA
because we're getting some feedback at
home thank you yes my question is in the
beginning the lenders in the bank that
were giving out these subprime loans
they knew they were risky one thing for
you know heating up things started going
bad why didn't they just keep the
interface for the homeowners low enough
that they could afford to pay
their mortgages so that we didn't end up
in prison banks are suffering now too
why don't they just keep the mortgages
interest low for you know so that people
could afford them they could stay in
their home that's that sort of a deal
then we wouldn't be this in bed of a
situation thank you well some are doing
that there you know when someone falls
behind on their payments or is going to
have trouble making a reset to a higher
mortgage payment they can call their
lender and work with their lender and
try and renegotiate what's happening is
it sits there are a lot of parties
involved in this so so it used to be
when you went to a bank you took out a
home loan if you had a problem you could
go and talk to your banker and work
something out but now the banker doesn't
actually own the loan now there's some
other investors that might be around the
world they might have a bunch of
different interests so it creates a very
tricky situation to to renegotiate that
thing I mean the caller is absolutely
right that that that in many cases might
be in everybody's best interest to
renegotiate these things and that is
happening more and more and that's been
a big emphasis of the Bush
administration of the Federal Reserve of
others trying to encourage these
renegotiations to happen but it's a
tricky thing it's sometimes harder to do
than it sounds when you just described
the simple version there were some
issues with a couple of years ago with
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac 2003-2004 did
this give any hint of what might be
ahead there were some accounting issues
with both of those organizations our
accounting issues were more we're more
confined to the way they report the
assets and liabilities on their books
and you know they're in fact the former
executives of Fannie Mae were actually
pursued for perhaps doing so
intentionally I wouldn't link that too
much to the current difficulties I mean
it does speak to this kind of unusual
situation where you have a quasi public
entity that that is privately owned but
but the current situation really has
more to do with both the losses on bad
loans that Fannie and Freddie are
encountering and not only that the fact
that often they get less for their money
on those bad loans and they then they'd
previously would if there are Kwazii
nonprofit organization obviously there
are not for profit
company actually their poor profit oh
there for a minute all right so that
they've they're entitled that's why they
have they have they sell shares on the
on the stock exchange next up is Bureau
Beach Florida on our Republicans line go
ahead for Neil Irwin go ahead Bureau
beach thank you for making my call I
have a couple of questions one is these
companies still hit giving out these
subprime loans to people looking for
mortgages it nothing not Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac I think she meant companies
in general terms I'm pretty I missed a
big chunk of that our company's still
giving out subprime loans with I guess
that i rarely not not very much it's
very hard if you do not have fairly
sound credit and and you know verifiable
assets and income very hard to get alone
these days in fact that's part of the
reason that Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
have been accounting for such a large
portion of of the home loan market is
because subprime loans are all but
disappeared from the markets even what's
called alt-a loans which is kind of
somewhere in between prime and subprime
those have dried up quite a lot as well
it's much harder to get those kinds of
loans the wall street journal this
morning reports on a related issue
mortgage insurers raised the bars their
headline mortgage insurers have been
dramatically tightening their standards
throughout the u.s. further squeezing
potential homebuyers the article says
done by growing defaults lenders are
offering borrowers fewer ways to avoid
purchasing private mortgage insurance
mortgage insurance required for buyers
who are unable to make the full down
payments or related a related issue to
the subprime collapse and it's what's
happening is throughout the the housing
industry the housing finance industry
companies that are finding to the
practices they engaged in 2000-2005
2005-2006 have burned them and they're
reacting as you might expect they're
charging higher prices clifton parkway
New York is next independent caller hi
good morning well good morning I have a
statement and then a question in order
to get this country going forward in the
housing market again I believe you're
going to have to start with the credit
bureaus because sometimes
the reporting is in what it should be
because it took me five years to get
mine where it's acceptable not that I
work / ready to begin with it was fair
but in any case and in order to save the
market right now there has to be a
reform on bankruptcy law as far as
chapter 13 that would kind of give
homeowners and foreclosure a chance to
work out something with their all
lenders and now my question is what is
considered a first-time fire because you
have a lot of people that were married
going to home they got the boars they
lost their home and now they want to buy
another home but I would say that was a
partnership to begin with and a first
time home buyer would be I would want to
buy it on my own today what's your
comment on that I believe different
programs first time home buyers have
different sets of rules is my
understanding many of them it's if you
you cannot have purchased a home in the
last five years and I'm not certain how
that deals with whether you'd previously
bought a home with the spouse or not
another point you raised on the
bankruptcy laws and whether whether they
should be changed to the bankruptcy laws
to make it easier for judges to
renegotiate or reset the terms of a home
loan and in bankruptcy that's actually
something that some Democrats on Capitol
Hill have advocated for over the last
several months it has not not really
gone anywhere the speaking of Capitol
Hill both Ben Bernanke and Treasury
secretary Paulson will be on Capitol
Hill today before the Senate Banking
Committee talking abuts the the fed
chairman's there to talk about federal
monetary policy but certainly they will
be asked about about what happened over
the weekend Treasury Secretary was also
intimately involved in by the way that
will be on c-span three this morning in
c-span radio at 10 Eastern the
Treasury secretary was involved deeply
in the bear stearns rescue compare the
two the people at the Federal Reserve
and at the Treasury Department view
these as there are some superficial
similarities don't misunderstand me but
but as fundamentally different kinds of
situations Bear Stearns suffered a
liquidity crunch meaning they couldn't
get access to short-term cash the people
who lent them money overnight every day
and show up and weren't going to win the
money they would have filed for
bankruptcy friday morning march 14th had
the Federal Reserve and Treasury not
step down primarily the Federal Reserve
so over the ensuing weekend in that case
they engineered a buyout of the company
what happened this past weekend Freddie
may from Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac is
different in the sense that no one in
the government believes that they were
looking at some short-term absence of
cash they were able to raise money on
debt markets they had plenty of cash
their regulator believes they have
plenty of capital this was not a cash
flow problem for Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac this was a market losing faith and
losing panicking about their longer-term
prospects and worrying that they just
don't have enough money to whether this
over many months and years ahead so in
that sense the efforts that the Treasury
Department was undertaking over this
past weekend was meant to bolster the
faith in Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac to
the long term whereas Bear Stearns was
more a short-term trying to avoid a
crisis a little more what would
congressional conservatives biggest
concern be over over this plant rescue
this plan to this plan by Treasury the
many of many conservatives in Congress
have not cared for the arrangement with
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac for many
years this is they've raised concerns
for quite some time their concern is
that for you know for many years has
been that this is a essentially a
government subsidy of private behavior
that it's a weird situation where the
government is subsidizing a private
company when that should should not be a
subsidized activity and if anything last
weekend has has given them more
ammunition for that argument that here
the government is talking about
potentially loaning money directly or
we're buying stock in these company
it sounds sounds like a kind of
nationalization that shapes on many many
conservatives and congressmen we talked
a little bit earlier about their their
stock price and I think we have a
graphic to share some of our viewers of
where their their their stock prices
brent has been fannie mae their stock
price their 52-week high in august of
last year nearly $71 and their 52-week
low was last friday at about 668 and
then Freddie Mac Freddie Mac's stock
price was at 67 67 20 last August and it
felt a 389 how they how did things go
yesterday after the trading open up
their shares were down some that they
were not down an epic amount compared to
Friday compared to many of the days last
couple weeks but they were down some
there what's many ways more important
than what happens with their stock price
is what happens with the price of their
debt I know it sounds obscure and
something that most people don't really
want to why is that important because
what's at stake is whether they can
continue borrowing money you know in
truth people in the government are not
too terribly worried about what happens
to shareholders shareholders took a risk
and if they lose some money that's the
risk they signed up for they want to
ensure that these companies continue
being able to go out into the debt
markets to sell bonds and use that money
to loan money to Americans to buy houses
and that's that's the big priority
Freddie Mac was able to do a three
billion dollar sale of short-term debt
yesterday went off quite smoothly that's
something that people at Treasury were
worried about over the weekend it went
fine so that was a good sign in terms of
on the stock side of things there any
idea of how much Freddie Mac and Fannie
Mae stock is held say by mutual funds
and pension on top of my head but a lot
this is the simple answer let's go to
epsilon e michigan democratic caller
good morning go ahead well i want to say
first of all my husband was out 30-year
job 30 years he was out and put his job
was given to mexican who work secret
then we old two thousand dollars on our
home we have lived it 29
come on leave them where you tell me to
do now I'm very sorry I would suggest
you if you you know if you do have
income and can find somebody to deal
with it I would call your lender and see
if you can negotiate something and work
out an arrangement if you you know have
a hard time doing that on your own there
are many community groups I would
contact perhaps a political leader or
someone else in your community who might
be aware of who in your town or city is
is a community groups private army
community group might counsel you on how
to work through this situation as a
group of neighbor works America that
does these sorts of things I would be
proactive about trying to get help than
trying to find a way to work this out
there are a lot of people including the
banks themselves who don't want people
to lose their homes who don't have to
the bank does not win if they have to
you know have a foreclosure and sell
your house at auction often the lenders
would rather work out a deal than see
that happen Daytona Beach is next
Republican line good morning go ahead
good morning c-span and thank you for
taking my call and good morning mr.
Irwin I was wondering wouldn't it be
better if we could set these loans up to
where it's like in the beginning like
half the prize did some of these loans
it seemed like the payments are way too
high I know I know Leonard's wonder
money put is possible but it just seems
like to me if they would just cut the
payments in half that it would help the
economy tremendously and it would help
the people trying to save their homes
also I want to make a comment earlier on
the gentleman that was on a hole
drilling yeah I'll sure I felt that it
was why not to drill offshore up until
now but maybe you know because of the
economy and everything we've been
[ __ ] everybody else's all dry maybe
it's now's the time to possibly drill
offshore I love Florida water too and I
I don't want any kind of mishap either
thank you for adding to Florida
mitchellville Maryland next on our
independence line go ahead mitchellville
good morning good morning you're on the
air thank you so much has been said
about the problems of the subprime loan
banks and loan
companies the public is not hearing that
the damage about the damage that's being
done to them can you give us a give some
idea of the kind of damage that will be
inflicted on people who are products of
the subprime loans quite a lot if you
took out a loan that that is under
unfavorable terms back when those loans
were being made in 2005-2006 the
beginning of 2007 and can't afford it it
can be a very difficult thing you can
end up you know having a loan reset and
potentially losing your house I I agree
that those are those are meaningful
stories but it's it's a broad story this
has affects a lot of people it affects
banks it affects individuals it's really
one of the huge stories of our time the
sunday New York Times had a long piece
on fannie mae and freddie mac and the
gist of the article is long protected by
ties to Washington Fannie and Freddie
balloon and they write about a couple of
comments made throughout the years going
back to nineteen ninety one Jim leach of
Iowa here Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac are
beginning to seem like arrogant
two-headed monopoly controlling ninety
percent of the market may 21st 2002 the
gorilla has outgrown the cage and we
don't know what to do with in Richard
Baker former representative with
Louisiana and several other comments too
including former fed chair Alan
Greenspan just a couple years ago the
Federal Reserve Board has been unable to
find any credible purpose for the huge
balance sheets built by fannie and
freddie freddie other than the creation
of profit but i wanted to you to address
this ties to Washington angle we have
our viewers take a look at the board of
directors of Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac board of directors is
Richard Simon siren the chairman and CEO
barber Alexandra Jeffrey Bose I Michelle
Engler Robert Glauber and Richard Carl
gets and the fannie mae board of
directors has daniel modesty president
and CEO stephen Ashley the board
chairman for Fannie Mae Dennis Beresford
Luis Freeh Barbara gains Karen horn
Bridget and macos ill of VMA consulting
Wesley
raw John sites jr. Greg Smith a former
Ford company vice president age Patrick
Swigert and John woof this this article
about ties to Washington why has this
been important for Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac well as you mentioned Alan
Greenspan Jim leach many others over the
years including many people in the
Clinton Treasury Department under bob
rubin including alan greenspan federal
reserve including the bush
administration in the first part of this
decade have have raised these concerns
over the years that these companies pose
a systemic risk that this is not a
long-term system that makes sense of
having this semi privates in my public
company but part of the reason that
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac have
continued existing in their in their
current form for all these years despite
these concerns raised by very prominent
people is that is that they've been very
savvy Washington players so in many of
the names you leave you read from the
board of directors are names that people
who live in Washington recognizes as
kind of movers and shakers in this town
they've been very good cultivating
relationships in Congress they've you
know they both have very active arms
especially more so in the past than
today all over the country where they
you know support community initiatives
they give away money to charities they
you know help local politicians look
good they might you know have a
groundbreaking for some project they
fund and they make sure to have the
local officials there for the ribbon
cutting ceremony it's it's been a very
elaborate effort over many years to
establish themselves as a kind of good
corporate citizen and an institution
that people in Congress have wanted to
support so the voice is criticizing have
been more voices in the world in a
bipartisan way this is a support on
either side both sides of the aisle
right many many strong conservatives
just like them but among mainstream
Democrats and Republicans many spores
next up in Atlanta Georgia on our
Democrats line go ahead for Neil Irwin
how you doing mr. Irwin my name is
Jonathan Harris and I have a question
and a comment my comment is is that I
think the government bailed out well
didn't really bail out Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac but I think the money moved
in that direction because a lot of
pension funds and other companies are
tied to that money that's the comment
Michael
do you know the numeric value of the
amount in terms of dollars that Freddy
million Freddy and you know the other
one contribute to our economy it's hard
to measure how much they contribute to
the economy these are massive companies
again that are responsible for for about
seventy percent of home loans in the
first first quarter of the year their
accounting for a very large portion of
the housing market it is safe to say
that if if they were to disappear
tomorrow there would be a very serious
implications for the housing market
possibly a crisis you know if you think
things in bad so far the last year or
two with housing market it could get a
lot worse if Franny and Fannie and
Freddie we're not able to make loans
it's you know is this is this government
action bailing out pension funds that
sort of thing well they're this debt and
and even the company's stock is held in
a wide variety of kinds of institutions
so in that sense you could argue yes
let's go to Nashville next on our
independence line for Neil Irwin good
morning go ahead good morning thank you
my first time on c-span so welcome very
cool I have a question for your guests I
wonder if you can sort of give me a
brief trimmer or all of us a brief
primer on why Bear Stearns was bailed
out specifically I mean if a large
Hollywood studio went under or if you
know Microsoft went under the government
wouldn't bail them out so I'm kind of
curious about the surat the overall
rationale for that and also I wonder if
you could give us a little of your
opinions on on mr. Paulson every time I
see him he just seems like a bureaucrat
with not too many ideas or creativity so
the Bear Stearns situation was a was
very complicated when Bear Stearns was
not really the biggest investment was
the fifth largest investment bank it was
not a huge company and normally I think
it's safe to say that the government
would have happily let it fail but what
happened is in March the situation was
so tenuous on global markets that bear
stearns had had basically over the
course of a single evening went from
being a leave a four billion dollar
company eight billion dollar company
something like that to being worthless
they were going to file for
krups in the morning and so bear stearns
had all kinds of relationships and and
contractual arrangements with other
banks other financial institutions all
over the world there's something called
the the repo market which is short term
debt so if you own a money market mutual
fund say with Vanguard or fidelity any
any mutual fund company your mutual plan
might have owned some of their overnight
debt and that might have lost value that
might have been had to be dumped rather
the assets behind though that debt would
have had to be dumped also Bear Stearns
was involved in derivative contracts
which are which are these complicated
financial structures with companies all
over the world that market would have
seized up and become very problematic
had bear bear stearns been able to fail
rapidly so in the view of Federal
Reserve Chairman Ben Bernanke and New
York Fed President Tim Geithner and
secretary Paulson it was a it was a very
tricky situation they did not love
having to do it but they felt like they
had no choice to preserve the world
financial system secretary Paulson he's
a former obviously everyone is entitled
to their opinion he is a former CEO of
Goldman Sachs he he is not a dumb man he
is a very smart man and very
hard-working whatever your thoughts on
his performance to this episode I'm that
caller mentioned Bear Stearns this this
Bank in California indymac made news
obviously last week with with the kind
of a not a run on the bank but certainly
limiting withdrawals and some issues The
Wall Street Journal reports this morning
they have reopened they halted their
foreclosures on its loans tie this into
what happened last week with Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac sure they're related
only in a sense that they have the same
underlying cause which is consumers and
have become overly indebted and in the
case of Fannie and Freddie they there's
a question about the long-term capital
that these institutions have in the case
of indymac the bank they they simply
weren't able to raise enough deposits to
cover their
they you know they've had experienced
losses on the home mortgage loans and
other kinds of loans they were making
more than they could afford and so the
FDIC on Friday the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation which ensures bank
deposits took over the bank there now
overseeing it there's a FDIC government
employees technically the CEO of the
bank right now so they're ensuring by
the way that you know we've see pictures
yesterday of people lining up out front
of the banks it's a there's really not
much need to do that the government's
takes over deposits are federally
insured how much your gmails knowledge
okay so people can still write checks go
to the ATM there's not really need for
panic this is in the 1930s before those
kinds of structures were created but but
it is a very difficult situation for any
Mac shareholders Lake Charles Louisiana
good morning good morning mr. Irwin
Nathan Curtis here I have a question
about the way that Fannie Mae has
operated in the past I think it was
mentioned earlier in the conversation
and that they are now requiring that the
poor making alone that the resources and
income be proven before the people get
the loan it seems that that was if they
were not doing that before that was not
a good business practice absolutely
right and i think the the company's
making those loans where they did not
verify people's in common assets would
very much agree with you now some of
them aren't even in business Little Rock
Arkansas on our Democrats line good
morning go ahead good morning I think we
got a look at something from a macro
perspective as well especially to those
individuals who are concerned about
bailing out homeowners who may be on the
verge of foreclosure I say this is
person who works in a non-profit housing
and does counseling that person loses at
home that affects the next homeowner
that affects the tax base which is your
fireman your police in your schools so I
think there should be a desire from
whatever are from whoever to help these
people who are losing their homes thank
you thank you I think no one has
anything but some
thief or people who you know earnestly
tried to buy a house and are now having
trouble making their mortgage payments
again there are many organizations out
there earlier I should have mentioned
there's a there's a line that was set up
by an alliance between the government
and and all the mortgage company is
called believe the numbers 1 800 hope
now you're right yes the hope now
Alliance is meant to help people find a
counselor and work through these
situations when they arise now this move
by the administration to bolster Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac comes in the midst
of that house and senate working on a
housing bill CQ writes a little about
that key differences in the underlying
housing package which includes a
modernization of the FHA and a plan to
help bars at risk of foreclosure keep
their homes still must be resolved but
with Fannie and Freddie potentially
imperiled lawmakers are expected to come
to some agreement Senate Banking
chairman Chris Don who will hear later
this morning said he would preferred
intellectually to move the backstop plan
for the two companies separately from
the housing legislation a problem makes
more sense to do it as one package I
think that's the better way to proceed
how does this move by the administration
complicate what they're trying to get
done on the hill people both in the in
the congressional leadership and in the
bush administration are quite confident
they'll be able to pass this bill with
the with the new stuff over the weekend
to to help the Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac they believe they'll be able to pass
in the next week or two now we'll see
the this legislation has been out there
for a long time the idea of creating a
stronger regulator for Fannie and
Freddie the idea of of some kind of
government effort to help people who are
risk of being foreclosed upon these are
these are bills that these are ideas
that have been working on for many
months with mixed results so again
gresham leadership and the
administration both think this will pass
very soon and be signed we'll see
included in it adjust of what the
administration is calling for that that
Treasury will make available to Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac be able to back them
us back them up with more access to to
catch it doesn't actually provide new
cash to the company's what it does is
allows the Treasury Secretary to
negotiate to expand the amount of money
they can borrow or even invest in them
directly after
next up is Chicago on our independence
line good morning yes it seems to me
that the reason we had Freddie Mac and
Fannie Mae in the first place is because
there wasn't enough money allocated in
the capital markets to tell people by
home now if this is this is true is that
true that is true okay now it seems to
me that the value of our economy of our
money at the other day all comes from
the value of the workers the work that
the workers in this society are capable
of and do every day now if that society
isn't even going to pay these workers
enough to make them attractive enough
borrowers to house themselves isn't that
a failure of our system well it's been a
difficult several years for for many
many workers wages did not through this
expansion since 2000 wages for the
median worker meaning the person right
in the middle have not not risen when
adjusted for inflation so I this is
indeed been a tough several years for
many many American workers you write in
the Washington Post you cover obviously
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac do you also
cover the housing industry I really
cover the the economy I cover US
economic trends in the Federal Reserve
let's go to let's go to West Hills
California in the San Fernando Valley
good morning on our Republican line go
ahead good morning it's a probably a
pretty basic question but could you just
briefly tell me what Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac stand for and also how they
differ from each other if at all and how
they differ from say a regular
commercial bank like Bank of America or
city bank or something like that thank
you Fannie Mae stands for the federal
national mortgage association I believe
Freddie Freddie Mac I should know this
not I'm not it with some uh put it off
forgiven we could we can put it up our
screen your Federal Home Loan Mortgage
Corporation for freddie mac and fannie
mae's federal national mortgages that
one right I'll throw curvature what is
soundly may stand for what are they all
about students it's yes in the are
interested in loan the how they differ
from from a commercial bank is that they
are solely focused on home loans first
of all and they are not a retail
institution they you cannot go into a
fannie mae office to get a home loan
what you do is you go to your bank and
then they make you the loan and then
they sell that loan to Fannie Mae or
Freddie Mac and and Freddie Fannie and
Freddie they can either hold on to the
loan and take take the money themselves
where they can package it as a security
that gets sold off on world markets now
that institution sells it to Freddie
Freddie Mac or Fannie Mae to get the
debt all that air but say you take out a
two-hundred-thousand-dollar home loan
the bank sells it to Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac they get two hundred
thousand dollars back they can now make
another alone and so your bank isn't
limited by the number of deposits it has
it can it can keep making home loans in
your community the way they're different
they're not all that different Fanny is
bigger but but they're fundamentally
quite subdued Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac
ever get involved in packaging these
loans together as investment they would
they wouldn't need yes they do that they
packed them together investments some
which they hold on to as for their own
portfolio some of which they sell off to
pension funds to you know any kind of
insurance company mutual funds any kind
of investor all over the world next up
is York Pennsylvania on our Democrats
line go ahead no we're going to go to
Bristol Township Pennsylvania go ahead
Bristol you're on the air hi can you
hear me yes I can yeah I just want to
ask something it just seems to me that
ever since Bush got in there's been a
lot of dismantling of certain things
like you see a you know you bail out
there Bear Stearns you know poisoning
you know toys food and drug
administration seems to be dismantling
um how can we correct that and has it
been worse since the Bush administration
came in is there a big difference
between the Clinton administration with
Fannie Mae and the Bush administration
thank you actually it's interesting the
clinton ministration had some of the
same reservations about the the current
structure of fannie mae and freddie mac
as the bush
ministration now there are questions
whether on financial regulation
generally on the way that banks are
overseen the way that all kinds of all
kinds of financial regulation occurs
whether a kind of relaxed or more you
know less attentive regulatory
environment contributed to the current
crisis and leave to other people to
debate but there are many people who
would argue that yes it did let's go
next to destin florida republican caller
welcome go ahead hi good morning good
morning I just I wanted to talk about
Lindsey Graham I'm sorry chef morning
you're breaking up a little bit on us
going repeat what you just said I want
to talk about Senator Graham and the
initiation of the legislation that kind
of caused this this disaster and i also
want to talk about eliot spitzer in his
case i believe he was suing the federal
government because these loans have been
illegal for so long and and he was
trying to rectify that before all of
this happened that's it thank you there
have been many investigations and many
efforts to look at some of the
inappropriate lending that was occurring
during during the housing boom there was
plenty to go around not just New York
state that Spitzer may have been looking
into but but all over the country
especially on the coastal areas and the
places where housing prices were rising
most rapidly it's clear there was some
some some behavior that was just bad
business decisions another behavior that
may well turn out to be illegal in
covering this story and talking to
people at Fannie Mae Freddie Mac did
anybody tell you say well we saw red
flags earlier we saw this early outside
the companies outside the companies many
people have been worried for many many
years that these companies were exposing
themselves to big risks knowing they had
this government the implied government
backstop even though it was not
officially part of the law so there
there have been red flags for many years
but not inside the company you haven't
heard from anybody that's I we saw this
when I made note of this inside the
company they are very careful monitors
of their own risk I would not be
surprised if they saw some red flags
that conditions been deteriorating in
the last you're so long islands next
Democratic caller go ahead
good morning good morning gentlemen um
mr. Irwin I you know your last chord
touched on something um Eliot Spitzer
had been suing um he'd gone off after
some very powerful political people in
my area out on Long Island and they had
said that the you know it was it was
they were using environmental money HUD
money and what the developer was doing
it was building these unaffordable
houses for people basically just
financing the loans using their name and
their social security numbers whatever
to get them the financing and then he
would just foreclose on the houses and
this was on 2001 Eliot Spitzer had had
it had to invoke tweed which was like a
boss tweed law because it was so much
corruption and like I said this is back
in 2001 they know they had known that
this was going on and if you just look
in the state attorney general's website
on Earth Day 2001 he had brought this I
members in front of the stock exchange
or something and he made a big speech
how he was going to correct this and but
then they had said that the whole all
the files and documents were in building
seven okay New York would give our
guests a chance to reply I don't know
the details of that case but it's it's
not the kind of thing that has much
bearing on the on the current situation
what's happened the last few weeks is a
is concerns about the long-term capital
position of these two companies going
forward and in the years ahead or you
what do you watch index with Fannie Mae
and watching the debt markets a lot
again these are kind of obscure things
that people don't pay a lot of attention
to but but their ability to continue
borrowing money at rates that are not
too far above what the US government
borrows at is is the best indicator of
how they're holding up to New Mexico Las
Cruces is next for Neil Irwin good
morning mr. Irwin you said something
that was a little I think misleading to
the general public and that was that you
know that Fannie and Freddie were
involved in the worst of these loans the
worstest prime loans and that really
isn't true the point was made by Paul
Krugman and Bernie Frank that what has
happened is that these really bad loans
where were secured
I on Wall Street and then sold and then
around the world and Fannie and Freddie
actually had some control of the loans
that they made and there were some
parameters set there the problem has
that now has happened is that all of
housing the value of housing has
declined and as a result of that decline
in value you now have people who would
ordinarily have good loans in trouble
because the value of their loan is worth
less than the house so i think you
should clear that up for the audience I
if I said that I misspoke it's true that
Fannie and Freddie were not making
subprime loans loans that were bought
and packaged by Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac were almost exclusively prime loans
meaning verified income standard kind of
income to debt ratios that they're
appropriate but what's happened and the
caller is exactly right what's happened
is there's always some losses even on
good loans high quality loans even good
times there's always some delinquencies
and foreclosures now what's happening
because home prices are falling so much
when those occur Fannie and Freddie they
can't the lender ultimately can't can't
sell the house for as much as they
previously could so the loss on those on
those smaller number of bad loans is far
more than anyone expected so that's
what's going on Raleigh excuse me
Columbus is next Columbus Ohio on our
Democrats line go ahead thank you for
taking my call it's all about the way
that America is being fleeced when you
look around they structure these
programs to where there are going to
los a caller Raleigh North Carolina is
next Republican caller go ahead yes sir
if you have a look hello you're on the
air rolling Raleigh North Carolina go
ahead yes sir if you do have a loan with
one of these Institute's Fannie Mae in
d-mat that nature are they going to be
assumed by another financial institution
do we do fall what do you suggest we do
with us in the case of indymac if if the
bank that you pay your mortgage to is
failed it should not affect you at all
you just keep paying your mortgage on
time it will hurt you if you don't what
will ultimately happen is the FDIC may
sell any Mac to another bank it may find
some other way to dispose of it but and
so there might be you know ultimately
another bank that you're paying your
mortgage to that ultimately buys indymac
but but for the for the near term it
doesn't affect what you did all same
with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac their
problems first all you probably don't
even know whether they own or package
your loan so so this should not really
affect your day-to-day behavior in any
significant one more call for Neil Irwin
we go to Eastern Connecticut on our
independence line go ahead yes hello I'm
not surprised at the indymac bank
failure because i went to a first time
buyer seminar in august 2005 when i
spoke to the people there there was only
one other person with the seminar with
me he had a bankruptcy and foreclosure
he was looking to get a home mortgage
they said no problem and I said how many
people have you turned down in the last
two years of Brian house and the
gentleman and for me and said we haven't
had anybody I've never known of anybody
we've turned down in two years and I
said I don't see how a bank can operate
like this so I left and said I'm not
interested in dealing with those people
so I'm really not surprised at if this
is their policy what this has happened
because that's what that was at the
height of in California at the
California at the time and that was at
the height of the escalation home prices
thank you well yeah during during the
boom years 2005-2006 there were a lot of
institutions including indymac we now
know
making loans that made no sense and the
college exactly right there were people
who really had no business getting a
home loan for a large amount of money
who were getting them and there was a
lot of money flooding into these kinds
of investments and and a lot of money
has been lost as a result Neil Irwin a
graduate of Columbia University School
of Journalism covers economics issues
for the Washington Post you can read his
articles of Washington Post calm and
we've linked to a couple of year
articles today and over the weekend
about the Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
situation at c-span dot or thanks for
joining us thanks for in just a moment
we're going to be joined by a
representative jerrold nadler who chairs
the subcommittee and judiciary looking
at detainee interrogation that's next
first though political update to the
hotline we go Amy Walter the editor in
chief